I am so happy to say we are back CBS
mornings our family Vlad Nate Gail and
Tony are
here glad um I think you can now go in
the hot dad category it's your
story really Drew Barrymore with my new
title all right so Forbes is reporting
what is fubbing okay fubbing is when
people spend too much time on their
phones in the company of others people
are on dates they're in a meeting at a
party or even spending some time with a
significant other and all of a sudden
like there's a meeting going on and you
see somebody on their phone it drives me
but what does cubbing mean what is that
it's bone and snub bone and snub pick so
it's a pH okay it's a it's a
pH right it's a huge pet peeve of M I
don't know do you guys like when you're
sitting in a at a party or at a dinner
table and your kids or somebody in your
family or a friend picks up their their
phone in the middle of somebody's
conversation and starts checking their
and they go and usually when you're like
what are you doing they're
like you're like what the what the
what the
I like that point of a what the
can't well mate it's actually your story
let me take it from here um I like it
okay here we go curb reports living with
your ex after divorce is becoming a
trend now here's thing before you say
whoa wait a minute here's the reasons um
you can keep the same routine when
you're staying with your ex because the
kids might be involved or it's just a
routine that you're used to there's
financial reasons you know one person
doesn't want to move out now all of a
sudden I have to take care of all the
bills by myself so the question is what
do you think about this after a divorce
moving in with your ex I think get out I
think that's where I get sort of
interested really in this story is like
how does it affect kids yes and I'm in a
co-parenting dynamic and what works for
us personal boundaries and they evolve
over time or they develop or some go
away let me ask in the initial phases of
the breakup could you have seen you two
still staying in the same home well we
actually did a thing called nesting
which is like the kids would stay at
home and we would come and go as we were
transitioning almost like a schedule and
we wanted to keep it stable for the kids
and I think the more you keep in mind
this lens of your children and what's
best for them if you do what you think
is best for your kids I believe you'll
find your way I Think It's Tricky I
Think It's Tricky when you have kids
that that staying in the same house only
works if you clearly have resolved the
relationship we're not going to be
together could you do it GA could you
handle that no no I could not but you
know I did if I was out of town then my
ex would come so much so that we got
along so well that when one of Will's
friends went through a divorce and he
said I know how you feel and he said how
do you know I feel he goes you've never
been through a divorce and the kid goes
but how your parent you're not your
parents are divorced they're always here
all the time it's because if I was out
of town he was there so when this kid
came he just he didn't realize he didn't
realize and I actually thought that was
a compliment I think what you want is to
create the environment that's best for
the kids and a counselor told me once
you have to love your kids more than you
dislike or hate your ex and I've never
forgotten that I've never forgotten and
we won't either thank you like
[Music]
that